los enlaces iónicos son los enlaces que
mantienen unidos a los compuestos
iónicos es decir que mantienen juntos a
los cationes y añón es un ejemplo muy
común de un compuesto que se mantiene
unido por medio de un enlace iónico es
el cloruro de sodio también conocido
como sal de mesa aquí tenemos una imagen
ampliada de los bonitos cristales de
cloruro de sodio y esto es algo que
pueden intentar en su casa agarren un
poco de sal de mesa disuelvan la en agua
y después dejen que el agua se evapore
lentamente si tienen suerte podrán ver
estos preciosos cristales simétricos al
menos para mí obtener cristales que se
ven tan bonitos es una de las cosas más
divertidas de la química y miren cuando
analizamos la forma de esos cristales
más de cerca su simetría que es muy
bonita nos puede dar información sobre
la estructura de estos compuestos a
nivel molecular los podemos ver con
diferentes técnicas como la
cristalografía de rayos x así
podemos observar la red cristalina y
obtener información sobre cómo están
acomodados o arreglados los diferentes
iones en los cristales entonces la forma
en que los iones estén acomodados o
arreglados puede determinar muchísimas
cosas acerca de las propiedades de esos
compuestos por ejemplo los enlaces
ionikos y el cómo están acomodados los
iones nos puede dar información sobre la
solubilidad del compuesto
solubilidad
y también otras propiedades como los
puntos de fusión
o de ebullición
e incluso los podemos relacionar con
otras cosas como por ejemplo la dureza
qué tan duro es el sólido iónico
entonces aquí en el cloruro de sodio los
enlaces iónicos mantienen unidos a los
iones de sodio con los iones de cloro en
ea + cl - y la fuerza de un enlace
iónico está relacionada con la fuerza
electrostática
la fuerza electrostática que existe
entre esos iones y voy a abreviar a la
fuerza electrostática como efe subíndice
entonces esta es la fuerza entre las dos
especies cargadas y es igual a una
constante acá por las dos cargas que
están interactuando entre la distancia
que hay entre esas cargas al cuadrado
entonces q1 y q2 son las cargas estas
son las cargas y por ejemplo en el caso
del cloruro de sodio q1 y q2 bueno q no
puede ser igual a uno más para el ión de
sodio y q2 podría ser uno menos para el
ión cloruro aunque igual podríamos
cambiarlos es decir que el cloruro
podría hacer que uno y el sodio q2 pero
eso no cambiaría lo que obtendremos en
esta ecuación y luego r al cuadrado es
la distancia entre los iones que
generalmente podemos aproximar diciendo
que es la suma
de los radios iónicos de los dos átomos
que estamos analizando así que podemos
usar la ley de colom para explicar
algunas propiedades que están
relacionadas con la fuerza de los
enlaces iónicos y el ejemplo que veremos
hoy es uno sobre el punto de fusión
punto de fusión entonces vamos a
analizar algunas tendencias en los
puntos de fusión y tratemos de
relacionarlos con las diferentes
variables en la ley de colo ok vamos a
ver los primeros dos compuestos que hay
que comparar cloruro de sodio y óxido de
magnesio el fluoruro de sodio tiene un
punto de fusión de 993 grados celsius
mientras que el óxido de magnesio tiene
un punto de fusión de 2.852 grados
celsius
y otro dato que conocemos sobre estos
dos compuestos es que si buscamos el
radio iónico resulta que en el fluoruro
de sodio la distancia entre los iones es
la misma que en el óxido de magnesio
bueno no son exactamente iguales pero es
casi la misma entonces si decimos que r
es aproximadamente igual para estos dos
entonces con las cargas podríamos
explicar la diferencia en los puntos de
fusión miren el punto de fusión es
básicamente una medida de qué tanta
energía necesitamos agregar a estos
compuestos para separar los iones
entonces podemos suponer que el punto de
fusión aumenta conforme efe también
aumenta y conforme la fuerza entre los
iones aumenta entonces necesitamos
agregar más energía para separar a los
iones y eso lo podemos ver en nuestro
primer ejemplo si analizamos las cargas
de los iones en el óxido de magnesio el
magnesio tiene una carga 2 más
y el oxígeno 2 - mientras que en el
fluoruro de sodio el sodio es uno más y
el flúor es uno menos
entonces suponiendo que r es casi la
misma que 1 por q 2 es cuatro veces más
grande en el óxido de magnesio que en el
fluoruro de sodio entonces al
multiplicar uno por q 2
el resultado es mayor para el óxido de
magnesio y es por eso que esperaríamos
que el punto de fusión fuera mayor y
también vamos a analizar el caso del
cloruro de sodio cloruro de sodio contra
el fluoruro de sodio
ok en este caso el punto de fusión del
cloruro de sodio es de 801 grados
celsius y bueno ya sabemos que el punto
de fusión del fluoruro de sodio es de
993 grados celsius y miren esta vez las
cargas en los iones son las mismas q1 y
q2 son uno más para el caso del sodio en
los dos compuestos y uno menos para el
cloruro y el fluoruro entonces en estos
dos compuestos uno por q2 no cambia pero
cambiamos el año fluoruro por cloruro
aquí incrementamos el y al incrementar r
que se encuentra en el denominador eso
hace que la fuerza electrostática
aumente otra forma en que podemos verlo
es que como r disminuye al pasar de
cloruro de sodio a fluoruro de sodio el
punto de fusión aumenta así que en cada
uno de estos pares el compuesto que
tiene el punto de fusión más alto
también
es el que tiene la fuerza electrostática
mayor y eso puede ser ya sea porque las
cargas son más grandes
q1 y q2 son más grandes o porque la
distancia entre los iones es menor estos
son algunos ejemplos de cómo podemos
relacionar las propiedades de compuestos
iónicos con la fuerza electrostática
usando la ley de colom entre educación y
el año